♪♪
At the beginning of season two
we meet Alex
In a very serene place.
All of the pain and the
frustration that she had been
carrying around for
years and years and years.
I think she had to get out of
the chaos
Bradley’s doing anything to say
that she is compliant,
she’s ready to be a team player,
but she also wants
autonomy.
She thinks she’s in control
and we find out by the end of
episode one
That is such an illusion.
You could have been my friend
but that did not happen.
I am an so glad it did not
because all you had to do
was be honest with me.
At the end of season one
There was an enormous thrill
that
Cory and Bradley shared,
in that Cory’s attachment to her
grew
in a way that was
unexpected to him.
We don’t know If it’s just an
infatuation or
it’s real but they are always
doing this dance
aound each other.
Camera's same mark.
Coming into the second season
was really a different
trip because we came in and shot
during covid
We were all very excited to be
going back into production but
also very scared.
We already started a season two
that then suddenly felt less
relevant.
When I read the new episode one
for season two
where you start
to feel all those little things
that we were not aware of then
the little sharing of food
the the little sneezes.
Just thought that was very
smart.
We shot a big big new years eve
sequence, In LA.
We did Times Square as you would
outside
a gigantic parking lot, it's
basically large enough for huge
green screen signs.
It was really fun to shoot it
and then create the world of
with VFX.
Standby camera two
The dance number was great and
they only rehearsed it once
An hour before we shot
Because we wanted it to look not
rehearsed
To do that on one of my first
days on set
Especially while we were filming
during a pandemic
To just have unbridled joy.
It was so funny, I couldn’t stop
laughing on the day.
Everybody was like
2020 is my year.
It was surreal to go back and
shoot the arrogance we all had
on that day in December of 2019.
To Kerry’s credit
she really came up with an
incredible storyline
about what happens when the
world closes in while
you’re just making plans
for your own life.
♪♪